uh have you read uh the plague by kamu
by any chance
years ago
years ago i have to read it again that's
really relevant well let me just sort of
ask you a question about it it describes
a town that's overtaken by a plague
it's blocked off from the rest of the
world
and it kind of reveals the best the
worst of human nature that's like how
people respond to that sort of the
encroaching
that their own mortality their own death
on the horizon i think what are the
messages in the book that
ultimately
like love for others so it's like a lot
of people want to become isolated and
they hide from each other but ultimately
the thing that saves you is is is love
which is one of the things i've
just watching this pandemic
you know with the distance with the
masks
that's all fine
but there's a distancing from people
of that that that um the tension the
breaking of the common humanity between
people that's one of the reasons i when
i came to austin
earlier this year just to visit
i fell in love with the city because
even with the masks and the distance
there was still um a camaraderie like a
like a i don't know just a love for each
other just a kindness towards each other
and uh that's what i took away from the
plague
mostly it's told the story of the doctor
who basically
gives in
and uh just gives himself as a service
to others and that that love is the
thing that liberates him from his own
conception of mortality the fact that
he's here he's going to die
what do you think about this
the effect of the virus we talked a lot
about biology but the effect of the
virus and the
the the fabric of the common humanity
that connects us
well that's what a pandemic does it
really
cuts that right because small outbreaks
are local they don't have global effects
but when you have something this big
we're
pretty much nobody
escapes
and not just
making people sick
it
changes your life right people lose jobs
they change jobs they move somewhere
else
they have all kinds of disruptions
you know kids can't go to school
it really shows you i mean i always like
to say
a tiny virus can bring
earth to its knees
tiny viruses you can't even see them
that most people don't even think about
most of the time
and the real effect is not just sickness
it's what it does to people because
in the end we are animals and most
animals like each other and they
interact they have great social
structures and that makes them
do well
and i guess the exception is people in
ai right
they can be on their own
well that's why you build robots that
you fall in love with that's right and
so i think when uh when a the real story
is what it does
to society for sure which has
ramifications way beyond the number of
people dying
in the vaccines and the tests and all of
that and this one has really made a big
rupture and you could tell not now so
much i think being out and about now
things look
pretty normal except you know for some
people wearing masks you would now never
know i mean
the airport this morning was completely
jammed people going and they're all on
vacation or wearing shorts right
so they're back to normal it's august
but last year it's really different in
new york where you're used to lots of
people on the street it was eerie it's
just quiet
but you know under it all people are
still
most people help each other when they
have to right
most people are willing to uh
if something happens to someone to reach
out and help them
you know they're always exceptions where
people are mean
and that's
you know that's just the way animals are
we're not the only ones that can be mean
to our own species
yeah but
i think most of the motivation for
everything that was done is to help
other people i mean i i do think that
the vaccine
manufacturers maybe not the leaders but
the people working in the labs really
wanted to get this out
quickly and help people right
yeah i think at every level people who
are contributing
really wanted to help other people and
feel proud that they're able to do that
so there's i view it as
you know we're never going to be 100
good
because animals are not
evolution
made us i mean we're lucky we somehow
rose above by having incredible brain
and so forth but a lot of our base
instincts are animals and you know they
chase each other and
and have alpha males and all that stuff
and we always have a little bit of that
in us but we do have some uh
humanity that this really ripped up it
really did
and i think for me someone who studied
viruses for over 40 years it's just
amazing that an invisible thing can do
that right
it goes back to the thing you found
fascinating which is a virus affecting
human behavior yes or uh behavior of the
organism
yes so
you know humans can make weapons and do
harm and you can see that but this you
can't even see yeah
you can and look what it has done and
it'll do it again there'll be more i
just
i wish we would be more prepared because
we know what to do we know we should be
making antivirals vaccines masks testing
masks making test mode modalities that
we can
really quickly redesign
but after sars1 all that went out the
door
people didn't do anything and that's why
we're in this situation so
i you know people ask me this all the
time are we going to be ready for the
next one
and i always say we should be we have
all the information we need to know what
to do
but somehow i think people forget
uh that said sometimes uh we we really
step up
when the tragedy is right in front of us
we do on the catastrophe so i don't know
somehow humans have still survived the
fact that we had nuclear weapons for so
many decades and we're still not blowing
each other up whether by terrorists or
by nation is amazing it's quite
surprising
so always after reading the pentagon
papers it's even more amazing right
so i don't know how we do it i i tend to
believe it's there's uh
there's that
you know at the surface you notice the
greed the corruption the the evil but
the core of human nature of the human
spirit is
is uh one in the scientific realm is
curiosity and more deeply is is kindness
compassion and like wanting to do good
for the world like i i believe that
desire to do good out powers all the
other stuff
uh by a large amount and that's why we
don't we have not yet destroyed
ourselves we kind of there's a lot of
bickering there's a lot of wars on the
surface but underneath it all there's
there's this ocean of of uh
love for each other i mean i think
there's a evolutionary advantage to that
and uh it would be a good explanation
why we still haven't destroyed ourselves
oh we had so many opportunities yeah if
you look at all the wars in history so
many yeah i was just my son was
telling me about the ottoman empire
right
it's just
you know war after war and then other
countries splitting up countries with no
regard to who's living where right
it's just
how can these people do this
yeah
it's fascinating human history is
fascinating and we're still young as a
species we have a lot they're very young
yeah more time to go and a lot
more ways to destroy ourselves
you